[Music]
ever since Moana came out Disney fans
have been wondering about several
potholes that were never really
addressed these theories are actually so
believable we really need Disney to come
and verify it don't forget to hit that
notification bell to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's check out these crazy Moana
theories something you want to hear
let's get right to the point because we
have a lot to cover these theories are
absolutely crazy but they actually kind
of connect with one another
connection to toffee D so the very first
Moana Theory focuses on the fact that
Moana and her ancestors are descendants
of the demigod to fede but they might be
slightly more than that the first clue
that would make this theory seem
plausible is the fact that Milan is
grandma as crazy as she seems clearly
has powers
I'm the village crazy lady that's my job
her dancing talent is obviously the best
part but have you noticed that the
stingrays obey her and dance with her
that's not normal no matter how
connected Island people would be to the
water sure it's Disney so anything is
possible but what if there's more to it
of course when the grandma passes she
also turns into a stingray just as she
predicted on her tattoo there has to be
something magical behind it right but
it's not just the grandma the Juana
exhibits supernatural strength to
remember how she easily pushed over the
Maui statue when she was trapped in the
cave she's also an incredible climber
and seems to figure things out really
fast come on would you be able to exit
that cave in the same way she did she
also shows a lot of force when she hits
things like coconuts she even managed to
knock down Maui with the oar and
considering how big Maui is you have to
admit that she showed some serious
strength when she first meets Maui she
hits him with the oar and he reacts of
course the reaction isn't as strong as
getting hit by Tama Toa antica but it
definitely shows she heard him several
times at least in the way she reacts to
being hit of course anyone would flinch
if they would be hit by an oar but come
on just look how big Maui yes
and or would probably break on him and
not cause him any pain at all so where
does - Phoebe come in in all of this
don't worry it'll all make sense and
Yvette's
the theme of the movie is the
cooperation between the ocean and defeat
II we see that take I can't touch the
ocean without being hurt which is why
the ocean can't be the one that returns
the heart the ocean clearly doesn't care
about Maui who's actually its demigod so
who does it turn to lawanna
so what if Moana is actually to feeties
demigod they do look alike anyways don't
they this also makes sense from the
point that the symbol featured on the
heart is the same symbol on mallanna's
boat if the ocean and take act can't
work together what if they're demigods
can of course in this case we mean Maui
and Moana so how does this all make
sense it's all down to mythological
symbolism Moana the movie comes with a
lot of symbolism that takes root from
several different cultures and we all
know that in Greek mythology various
leaders were actually descendants of
Greek gods we all know - fede basically
created the islands from the ocean and
filled them up with life which probably
includes humans - so what if she
actually also picked a human to become
her demigod
now he's back story also confirms people
can actually become demigods so this
would make sense
the humans which would be voyagers would
be guided and led by an actual chosen
one isn't that exactly what my Ana's
ancestors were doing and what Moana did
to mallanna's dad clearly skipped the
chosen one generation and maybe that's
precisely why he was so upset at the
whole situation maybe all the village
chiefs were demigods apart from him
which is why he didn't feel as confident
going beyond the reef
no one goes beyond the reef he thought
he could do it but he failed which cost
him his best friend's life honestly we
could go on and on about this are you on
board now okay here's the next theory
grandma Tala you know there just has to
be more to Grandma Halle than we know
she's just absolutely wonderful and one
of our favorite characters
she definitely represents the village
crazy ladies a hand to be fed every
village has someone like her
of course we mean that in the most
positive way possible because grandma
Tala is nothing but awesome this reddit
theory claims
Halla is actually the god of the ocean
who has chosen to come and live as a
human she's actually the one that gives
mallanna her epic quest so it would make
sense that she's a higher power that's
more involved in the whole thing than we
think
remember when grandma actually said to
Moana that her dad was basically just
like Moana this was to show that he had
exactly the same wishes to cross the
reef but what if she sends him on the
exact same mission to remember when she
also said she was there the day the
ocean chose her well we didn't see her
so what if she was actually the ocean we
also see her in the afterlife as a
stingray it's clear that she has a
similar connection to the ocean just
like Moana after she passes she also
travels with Moana which is why we can
actually see the ocean act as silly as
it does don't you think that it's humor
is pretty much the same as Grandma
Tallis on top of that
grandma's Hollow is actually really
confident in the fact that she would
become one of the stingrays after she
passes it's definitely not a coincidence
so if she is the god of the ocean then
Moana definitely has some godlike
ancestry right there's kind of more to
Grandma's Hollow than you think
well more than already being awesome she
might have a quite interesting past
according to these theories another
theory states that grandma Tala could
potentially be Maui's mother so let's
consider that she actually is the spirit
of the ocean since Maui is the oceans
demigod how would all of that work this
is where the whole thing gets really
interesting
what if grandma Tala was actually Maui's
mother and she knew he was a demigod
from the beginning Maui questions why
his human parents gave him up but what
if they were not human what if it was
Tala who has thrown him into the sea and
let the ocean take care and the ocean
was actually her but she never revealed
it and we know Maui can do anything but
float that's a pretty specific
disability for a demigod right so what
if grandma Tala was the one that made
floating which would basically mean
floating across the ocean impossible for
Maui because you know moms have to
enforce some boundaries after all isn't
that crazy okay so where does that leave
Moana well if her dad is actually
tallest son she clearly has some demigod
genes in her right it definitely
wouldn't be surprising to see that she's
got some supernatural power
the final Moana is a demigod theory is
actually pretty straight to the point
this is the one that is perhaps the most
popular by Disney fans it's the perfect
theory that actually has people's minds
blown and they change the way they see
mallanna's character seriously wait
until you hear this why do people spend
so much time theorize in this movie you
ask well when you have kids you're kind
of forced to watch Moana over and over
again so we can thank them for this
final theory that's absolutely nuts so
let's be realistic in the first part of
the movie mallanna was totally
unequipped and unqualified to deal with
the ocean
like seriously girl what were you even
thinking she didn't even know how to
sail a hands were pretty sure that's
something she should practice before
getting literally thrown into the ocean
as much as she wished to go out and sail
across the reef that came with
consequences something her and her dad
had in common it took her a while to get
the courage and it was only after
grandma Tala told her that this was what
she was supposed to do you know that she
was the chosen one and all of that damn
wanna then heads out to her epic quest
once again leaving puah the pig behind
to avoid him having the same faith as
her dad's best friend who his story is
never revealed and he doesn't really
play an important part in the movie but
we're pretty sure that's the reason the
pig didn't join her of course things
aren't easy the second time around
either Moana asks the ocean for help
after not knowing what to do and the
ocean delivers in the weirdest way
possible this is where things get a bit
weird but try to follow us mallanna
enters a horrible storm and for some
strange disney reason the storm
perfectly washes her up on Maui's island
yeah
thanks for the help ocean we're sure
there were way better ways to help Moana
so why did the ocean choose this
horrible way that could cause a lot of
damage she wasn't able to sell at all
and suddenly she's found Maui's Island
that's a pretty weird coincidence right
if this would be the case everyone would
voluntarily get thrown into storms and
wait for the best outcome we know that
didn't work for Anna and Elsa's parents
rip okay back to the subject why didn't
wanna ask the ocean to take her to
Maui's island in the first place well
the theory has it
Marana has actually lost her life during
the storm and the ocean turned her into
a demigod this would explain a point
from our first theory where we see
mallanna exhibiting a lot of strength
she's able to move a massive five tonne
statue she can fight she can take down
coconut pirates like it's nobody's
business and she's pretty much fearless
the change in her attitude is instant
and to be honest it's hard to believe
she could have so much adrenaline just
from finding Maui so what if that's the
solution mallanna became a demigod when
the storm washed her up on Maui's Island
don't believe it well we know that Maui
was thrown into the sea as a baby but we
also know that he was saved by what he
calls God's which could also be the sea
he a human was then given powers well
hold on a minute isn't that exactly what
happened to Moana she was practically
thrown into the sea and saved by the
ocean so where's the powers bit it's
there it just wasn't obvious the ocean
helped her in the most brutal way ever
it drowned her and in exchange Moana
became immortal you know where this also
makes sense when they jump into the
realm of monsters you heard it from Maui
himself no mortal could ever jump in the
realm and survive even says that Moana
is pretty much done for as she lands on
the ground but by some miracle she
survives it without even a scratch
come on Maui was more hurt in this movie
than Moana and they went through totally
similar stuff mallanna is clearly
powerful enough to be the superior
demigod even to Maui connect all of that
to the theory that grandma Tala is
actually the ocean to fully have your
mind fully blown seriously if we need is
need to come and confirm or deny these
theories because they seem pretty
believable the best part is that Moana
clearly has plenty of mythology in it so
literally anything could happen the
whole thing about grandma Tala is
honestly mind-blowing and it kind of
deserves its own movie just imagine a
whole movie about baby Maui hands up if
you'd watch that what do you think is
mallanna
actually a demigod and more powerful
than Maui come let us know what you
think in the comments and let's get to
the bottom of this and that's it for our
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]